know when you found out that we had
broken up how would you feel
um
relief no um
uh i i mean look i it's i was thinking
about it because i i was like catching
up on everything um
yesterday and
it's
i'm sad i mean
i'm sad because i know how sad
y'all are and i think for me i have the
and how it's heartbreak i mean life's
like getting an animal that you know is
gonna die at some point right you know
what i mean it's just that like they're
not gonna die there's no they're not
gonna know there's no way around it it's
like no one gets out alive and i think
that when you know someone is going
through something that you've either
gone through or you know it's just like
there's no way out but through unless
you want to anesthetize yourself and do
you know
there's no way you know what it is and
there's nothing anyone can do to take
your pain that's what's the most
frustrating
when people that you love are in some
kind of pain
uh in um a fraught situation where the
only thing they can do is feel it and
then heal it and like with an animal
dying or that there's nothing you can do
whereas if you were like ah
we got our podcast pulled down from you
you about here okay here's why it's
gonna be good here's why this is the
best thing that's ever happened to you
work stuff here's why you just dodged a
bullet you know i mean um you didn't get
to work with alec baldwin um
and
and uh
and but when i heard you guys like talk
about it it was you know i
my personal point of view as someone who
my best friend and sort of business
partner is an ex of mine that i dated
when i was much younger and he's like
very much like my soul mate my brother
and i believe that there is a type of
intimacy that i i want crave more than
anything which is
you know someone that you've been in a
romantic relationship with and now your
family
that to me is the most life affirming
the the most proud relationship i i have
and the most intimacy i have so
i like i'm happy that you guys like have
that yeah you know like that in the way
that you guys all are you articulated it
and also because it didn't happen
overnight right this has been on the
table for an entire year do we stay
together do we not so it's just it isn't
i think that i'm able to talk about it
objectively now because it we didn't
have one giant fight and then say [ __ ]
off you know it's been and it's also
like slow burn kind of but it also was
like
10 years is such a giant success and
helena bonham carter said it when her
and tim burton broke up she's just
because it ended doesn't mean it wasn't
a success
yes and half of her family died in a
plane crash oh my god
think about that yeah that's pretty good
thanks so she was definitely on purpose
when she said that what was that
did you know that yeah i know
what does one have anything like the
other man because dude how many people
do you know
there's something fascinating to me when
you really start like doing the math on
how many entertainers have had like
really horrendous [ __ ] happen to them
yeah uh like i remember one time i was
like um stephen colbert was on the daily
show or something and i remember being
like
look at this guy
nicest guy
doesn't have any trauma you don't have
to be traumatized to be a comedian the
funniest written someone's like you know
his parents yeah yeah like three of his
family members just like died in a plane
crash when he was 10 and got it
but uh but yeah i mean i just i think
that for
i i could not think of a way that
a more elegant way that y'all have
ostensibly navigated this in such a
mature way and i think that like you
know and
not to bring up
so i made a movie uh about this you know
in this movie i made the female brain
there was one whole storyline that was
about this couple it was sophia vergara
and dion cole and they've been together
for seven eight years and it's like our
brain is wired to kind our brain is
savage you know it's like we're kind of
wired to be madly obsessed and attracted
to each other for like two years the
amount of time it would take to make a
baby and then make sure the guy sticks
around to care for it and then we're
wired to kind of move it's the fact that
y'all have like overcome just despite of
our despite our money is that a true
thing you just said yeah we don't make
as much oxytocin a dopamine for someone
after like two years oh [ __ ] it makes
sense
but you guys i'm saying you have beat
the eye you are so your love for each
other and your care for each other like
you've built this despite biology like
you've over you know what i'm saying is
that why every relationship i've ever
had only lasted two years or even less
yeah you stopped producing dopamine
oxytocin for the person but then you go
look yes i want to [ __ ] everything that
moves that's what i'm wired to do but
i'm choosing
this i think i think that's the thing
about relationships is oh
thank you is that you
there's your guy bobby comes home and he
has a picture next to a guy who's
towering over him and he goes who's this
kalila who did i take a picture with and
it's a blake griffin by the way who is
great guy so funny it's
so funny yeah yeah no but like did stand
up at montreal and was hilarious yeah
like he's legitimately i just with blake
griffin